[Music]
well the cdc eviction moratorium ends
soon and our states ended last week
as bianca holman reports there is
government funding to keep a roof over
your head
if you're behind on your rent there are
millions of dollars available to help
keep you
in your home and government officials
are making the rental assistance process
more accessible very confident you know
just
the fact of knowing what your rights are
i think that is so important for
everyone today to understand
where to go how to get receive the
information who to contact
and just be able to understand how to
protect yourself in this day and age
as a proud hospitality worker kimberly
ireland who was impacted by the pandemic
had to navigate housing resource
platforms and she says
it wasn't easy leaders from state local
and non-profits
have changed that county commissioner
justin jones says there's now free legal
help and resources
through the southern nevada eviction
prevention program now that we really
have the system down
it's just so much more efficient we're
able to really get the people that
assistance as quickly as possible
we have all our partners from legal aid
from the court system
working with us to make sure that we
keep people in their homes
or if necessary that we get them
rehoused as quickly as possible
but don't wait give your landlord a
declaration using the cdc
form apply for rental assistance through
the chap website
also make sure to respond to the
eviction notice and request a mediation
help is here the resources are here but
we need
people to start the process if you're
behind on your rent or facing eviction
you can take action now by visiting our
website eight news now dot com
reporting bianca holman 8 news now